foreign
Chris is in Charlotte North Carolina hi
Chris welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up um I'll get right to it um me and my
wife recently started a side business we
both work full-time and kind of looking
to pay off a ton of Consumer Debt and
realize you can only save so much so we
we started this High business dog
sitting with the intentions of paying
off the Consumer Debt and I spoke with
my accountant last year
um and he suggested putting my two
children kind of on payroll right and
paying them to benefit
um you know investing into their Roth
IRA and maxing it out for them because
he suggested that you know they don't
pay taxes on that
um so that now kind of threw me for a
loop and I think that's what we're going
to plan on doing for this year and and
my question is we are pretty late to the
game with investing for ourselves right
and it kind of I wonder if it's foolish
to do that for them I I just recently
learned the power of compounding
interest so that's the reason why I'm
doing this you know and they're three
and five
um it just seems like a unique
opportunity because we don't plan on
doing this forever really just to pay
off the Consumer Debt and we're not
really
struggling we have a plan you know to
pay off the Consumer Debt and if it
takes a little bit longer because we're
paying our children investing in a Roth
IRAs
I'm an IRS auditor and I'm sitting in
front of you
and you paid your three-year-old
to do work
I'm not believing that the
three-year-old did any work and I'm
going to undo everything you did
in the audit You're Gonna Lose
your accountant is a
you have to be you have to be able to be
working if the child is actually working
you can pay them the market value for
their work
but you can't make a case that a
three-year-old
is actually working
be struggling to say a five-year-old it
happens to be walking dogs so we can do
this now an exception would be like I
did have a client one time who had a
baby who appeared in multiple diaper
commercials and made serious Bank the
baby was actually working and so yeah we
put that into an IRA for sure because of
the power of compound interest but what
you you have to be able to make the case
that they were paid
you know like Rachel for instance at 14
years old would go and do a three-minute
talk on the stage of why it's tough to
be Dave Ramsey's daughter
what it was like eight minutes okay
I'm sorry sorry we would work the events
though yeah it was not eight hours it
was a few minutes okay and and then she
would go work the book tables and I
would pay her a percentage of what the
kids books sold at the book tables back
then if she's a teenager and and it was
a it was a healthy percentage but I
didn't pay her a hundred thousand
dollars a year
you couldn't justify that to an auditor
you follow me so I mean yeah you know so
so you can't do that the dog sitting I
mean it really is it's not you know feed
the dogs watch the dogs play with the
dogs three-year-olds are not allowed to
work
okay I mean really think just use some
common sense okay yeah yeah what what
would you actually if you ran a business
would you actually hire the neighborhood
three-year-old to go over no you
wouldn't yeah I might hire the
neighborhood eight-year-old to help me
and there's a market value to that doing
dog sitting okay and you can actually
make a common sense case for that yeah
but the three-year-old still barely
potty trained oh my God and now we're
trying to potty train dogs no no no no
no no no no no no no no this doesn't
work so you know they so your accountant
is willing to set you up for losing an
audit which is why I'm saying I don't
think you need this accountant and Chris
and here's the deal too even if you wait
until they're 8 10 12 14 years old to
start this process they're gonna be fine
like they're gonna be fine you don't
have to start at three you know so you
can do this in a morally legal way
eventually that's that's great what he's
saying that he's going to not do the dog
sitting thing after he gets out of debt
so it's not the opportunity's not going
to be there no I'm just saying in
general though in general they can go
and like y'all could start something or
you know whatever life looks like when
they're act when they actually are able
to contribute and it's not like you're
kind of you know and you don't need to
be behind on your investing
when I did this for our three kids you
have to file a tax return on the kid and
there is some taxes due
okay there's no income tax to you but
they're going to get hit with FICA and
uh self-employed income and so each one
of them I filed a tax return I looked at
their actual income I had to make sure
it was market value or slightly above
market value for the duty that they were
performing and I filed a tax return I
paid the taxes they kept the money that
they earned and I put the equivalent
amount into a Roth IRA on their behalf
all of them were teenagers by the time
we were doing that yeah and
um or thereabouts I mean Daniel might
have been 12 I mean or something but but
uh
I mean they were you had a justifiable
case and we were baby step seven and my
investments were okay I didn't do this
kind of stuff you know and then my and
then I'm going to retire broke but my
kid has a 16 year old has an IRA no
right right yeah it's a balance and
again Chris I think the urgency that
you're feeling is I mean he just said
he's like I just learned about compound
interest oh my gosh exciting yeah so
there is an urgency and I think you know
again the heart behind it's incredible
absolutely and to be able to set our
kids up really well
and there's time to do that is what I
would say so don't let this urgency of
this new information make you make bad
decisions and lead you into something
that's just not wise how often do they
audit well I mean if the thing is you
the point is not are you going to get no
no I know I know there's like a moral
thing here but but when you said that I
was like man I wonder how often like
well you just you have to be able to
defend everything you do in an auditor
you shouldn't be doing it yes totally so
that's not only it's not only proper tax
process but it's also the moral and
ethical thing to totally yes yes for
sure like we've just finished this
unbelievable two and a half year audit
just similar to an anal exam at Ramsay
and so uh but we have paid every
stinking dime that we've ever owed and
so we've not lost a single category not
a single category and they've turned
over everything in this building
um you know
and uh you know so but but we're
Fanatics about paying the exact thing
amounts everything being honest every
bit of cash we collect is taxable income
we don't have any side gigs going every
it's very traceable and it has nothing
to do with I like taxes or I think taxes
are wonderful or it's my way of being
generous it's not taxes are extortion
they're theft by your government they're
horrible I hate them I hate the IRS but
it has nothing to do with that it has to
do with my Integrity it says it doesn't
say anything about them when I cheat on
my taxes or something about me
and so of course that's not aiming at
you but that's just a further soapbox on
this whole thing so good motivation bad
information
good thoughts bad timing
so later on when you're at baby step
seven and you've got and your
retirement's underway and you can do
justifiable market value labor for your
kid like if your kid is 16 in a few
years and they're doing it they got this
wonderful dog sitting business that they
spring up because Mom and Dad used to do
it and they go make a bunch of money you
could do what I did with our kids and
it'd be perfectly fine no issues there
at all uh and you'd be teaching them
entrepreneurism in their teens which is
a great idea so that's the kind of thing
you're looking for bad timing though you
can't unless the three-year-old's in a
diaper commercial three-year-olds don't
have a market pull-up commercial
pull-ups okay at three yeah hopefully
hopefully yeah that's good we're in the
middle of that we have a three and a
half year old I thought oh yeah you
don't want Charles watching your dog
oh
now Amelia the eight-year-old oh yeah
she would be yeah she's pretty she knows
how to take care of Jim better than I do
I mean she's pretty much game on yeah
phenomenal
but not the three-year-old no no they're
yeah I'm not gonna say it okay they're
just they're fine they're fun that's
what we're gonna say what are you gonna
say no I just I was saying about all of
them not just not just that one Dave
likes babies Papa Dave wants babies once
they hit like two when they're doing the
pull-ups
I'm good that's completely until you can
ski yeah
there's a transition period there this
is the Ramsay show